the war on the ground is tragic we we
all understand that but the economic War
uh if you aside from the human cost
maybe including the human cost is bigger
uh you know the starvation in Sudan uh
might not make the TV as much as
atrocities in Ukraine but it's going to
happen and probably more lives will be
lost that way
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and this is
a show for you if you want honest
conversations with Fascinating People a
brilliant returning guest today is an
economist lawyer investment banker
author commentator speaker is all sorts
of things we get them on every time
there's a looming economic disaster or
an actual economic disaster Jim Rickards
welcome back to the show thank you
constantly thanks Francis great to be
with you it's good to have you back uh
so last time we had you on the show was
about two years ago right as the first
instance of lockdown here here in the UK
and we had you on with another good
friend of ours people malgram and the
things that we were talking about
particularly was the both of you were
predicting that there would be inflation
coming as a result of everything that
was happening in the world at that time
the actions that the governments in many
countries around the world were taking
and we're now starting to see that your
predictions were entirely correct so
what do you make of the economic
situation we find ourselves in now
well that's that's a big question of
course uh the inflation's here so we for
I'll say two years from 2020 to uh and
over the course of 2021 there was a big
debate in economics and among analysts
uh about inflation versus maybe
disinflation uh you know still have
inflation but at a lower rate
um and that that debate kind of went on
through uh all of uh uh most of 2021 but
that's over inflation's here there's no
more debate about the the new debate is
will it persist will it get worse which
it might or will it um be subdued in
some way now I have actually been in the
camp again you can see the inflation
coming it's here
it's going to persist for a while uh
that's you know that's the big question
we'll be we'll kind of tell off quickly
over the next few months or will it kind
of be the Domino thing for 2021 sorry
2022. I definitely lean to the latter
however going out you know maybe nine
months to a year I see that curve
bending uh and getting into a more
disinfectionary mode not for good
reasons um that has very uh what does
have to do with the FED in the sense
that um
they painted themselves into a corner
there's no way to escape the room they
can subdue the inflation but at the cost
of a very severe recession not a mild
recession a very severe recession so the
question is that to me the biggest
question economics is will the FED go
down that path do what they have to do
do the only thing they can do uh to
subdue inflation at the cost of a very
severe recession and something like a
stock market crash or will they see that
coming they'll be the last to know we'll
we'll all see it before they do but
they'll be the last number it's because
they rely on flood models and they're
kind of in their own economic
forecasting bubble and they're very
defective ways of thinking about the
economy and they're very much a creature
of inertia there are a whole lot of
reasons why the FED is not Nimble it's
kind of quite the opposite but they'll
see it eventually probably when it's too
late and will they block at that point
and stop rate hikes and maybe even
reduce rates that could save us from the
recession but that will just amplify the
inflation so rather than say which one's
going to happen I prefer to lay out
those two paths and then just watch it
very carefully but more to the point
we've seen this movie before this is a
replay and I I think it's on um you know
you hit the remote control for double or
triple speed it's going to happen faster
but this is a replay of everything that
happened from 2013 to 2019 and and into
2020 which was I'll just go through it
quickly so 2013 May Bernanke says we're
going to taper asset purchases that's
that's money printing quantitative
easing whatever you want to call it
the market you know tanks bonds go down
everyone's like oh it's over uh the
Bernanke block but finally in November
2013 they said okay the taper begins
they were still printing money but at a
slower rate and that matters that went
on until late 2014 the table was over
they stopped buying new assets they said
okay here come the interest rate hikes
except they didn't come for another year
it wasn't until December 2015 that then
Janet Yellen finally raised rates and
then another year for the second rate
increase so it's December 2016. so it
was really really slow took two and a
half years but they got to two rate
hikes but then Here Comes Jay Powell and
then like Cloud work boom boom boom 25
basis point hikes every meeting and all
the Fed was trying to do was was to get
back to normal they were trying to get
interest rates to maybe two and a
quarter two and a half get the balance
sheet down to you know something like
2.5 trillion they never specified it
that would have been a reasonable level
okay now interest rates are kind of
normal two and a half balance sheets
down around two and a half trillion
we're back to normal we finally got
through the the global financial crisis
in 2008 we kind of we undid all that
stuff well what happened
um from October 1st 2018 to December
24th 2018. the stock market dropped 20
that was the the December 24 2018 we
called the Christmas Eve Massacre stock
market went down three percent in one
day
um but the FED uh was tightening into
the weakness as they always do and the
last interest rate hike it was uh
December 16th or 17th within a day or
two but mid-December 2018 they were
still hiking and raising rates and that
was the last straw and then the market
just tanked and then finally Jay pal got
that message uh first week of January
2019 he says okay we're that's it we're
going to be patient use the word
patience one of these code words you
have to get the code book out and see
what it means but patient means we won't
raise rates again without giving you
Advanced warnings so you get out of your
calorie trades or whatever and then he
went further said huh looks like we've
got to cut rates and they did and then
by early 2020 here comes the pandemic
and then they took rates all the way
back to zero and then they started QE I
don't know six seven to call what you
want they took the balance sheet to
seven and a half trillion dollars after
getting it down to three and a half
trillion so look at that whole sequence
from 2013 to early 2020 including the
pandemic what happened they they tapered
the asset purchases they raised rates
they sank the stock market then they
said okay no more rate hikes then they
cut rates and then they start at QE and
by by April 2020 where were we zero
rates back down to zero and the balance
sheet was a seven and a half trillion
after getting down to about uh three
three and a half trillion so that was a
big
um
uh a circle they ended up back where
they started from but the point being
they failed to normalize they failed to
get rates where they wanted they failed
to get the balance sheet where they
wanted they did sink the stock market
okay now two years forward here we are
again what are we doing they just raised
right set the at the March meeting
they're going to raise them again in May
and that's the easiest forecast I've
ever made 50 basis points May 4th boom
you can you know you can count on it and
they're going to announce uh by the way
I don't have a crystal ball the FED told
us this I mean that's the thing about
the fact they may be wrong but they're
transparently wrong so they tell you
what mistakes they're going to make in
advance so that's the pet forecasting is
actually fairly straightforward because
you just have to believe them uh so uh
so they're going to raise rates again in
May probably 50 basis points they're
going to announce a reduction in the
balance sheet whether they actually
started in may they probably will 100
billion a month reduction in asset
purchases so that's QT quantitative
tightening in other words they're
running the same play book they tried to
run or they started to run in 2013 2014.
but here's my question they failed the
last time why do they think they're
going to be any more successful this
time why do they think they can get out
of this and the answer is apartment the
answer is they cannot
without a recession now if you and this
is what Larry Summers has been saying I
think he's right and you know everyone's
jumping on board Alan Blinder and all
these other big brands from Princeton
but uh but the point being uh they can
normalize rates in the balance sheet and
they can stop inflation but not without
causing recession and not without
causing a stock market crash
so the big question for the next year is
will the FED do that and they may or
Walker did it
um or will they balk again at which
point you might rescue the market but
the inflation is just going to go wild
that's that's the debate but but but the
thing is about framing it that way
you've got two pass and we'll get
signals along the way we won't we won't
be the last to know the FED will but we
will you'll be able to see this coming
okay uh and Jim just remember that most
of our audience are not Financial
experts so we've given us the sort of
financial expert assessment of you know
the FED is going to have a choice
between controlling inflation by likely
causing a recession or allowing
inflation to run rampant uh how do some
of the more recent things that we've
seen play into this because we don't
have time to get into the war in Ukraine
the Rights and Wrongs of all of that but
in terms of the economic impact
obviously Russia and Ukraine until the
world's biggest producers of wheat uh so
you've got food inflation that may be
coming as a result of that but also for
other reasons oil and gas and everything
that's happening there how are those
events are going to be affecting
ordinary people's lives in your opinion
well in in a big way and it's going to
get a lot worse um and here pardon me
we're talking about global uh Supply
chains by the way I just finished
writing a new book it won't be out until
later this year it's funny I wrote a
book about the supply chain but the
publication is delayed by the supply
chain they don't it is they don't they
don't have paper you know the paper
comes from Finland I talked to my agent
she said uh I represented author his
book is done it's printed but they can't
ship it because they don't have
cardboard for the boxes and even if you
do there may not be drivers uh there's a
queue with the printers they're doing
triage on books uh you know no need to
kind of belabor that but the point the
point is my supply chain book is being
held up by the supply chain but anyway
that is uh a big deal and there and I'll
come back to the Ukraine connection
because it's huge but um the supply
chain was breaking down before the war
in Ukraine uh that was breaking down
beginning in 2018 with Trump's trade
Wars we don't have to debate the pros
and cons of tariffs and trade Wars uh
there are two sides to that but that
there's no question that that disrupted
the supply chain when um Trump put
tariffs on imported uh you know solar
modules and consumer durables and
refrigerators and and air conditioners
everything coming from well it's coming
from everyone but it was clearly aimed
at China China retaliated by saying
we're not going to buy any more U.S
soybeans and they bought their soybeans
from Brazil and that sounds like oh okay
you changed your purchase order from the
US and Brazil what's the big deal it's a
huge deal they they move them on ships
you know you got to redirect all that
ship traffic change all those shipping
lanes break a lot of long-term contracts
um the US has to scramble to say well we
got to sell the soybeans to the Dutch
because the Chinese aren't buying them
anymore and that's that you know so the
the point being the logistics the trains
the the the the trend lines the cargo
Lanes uh the purchase or the currents
could all get scrambled so that was
going on
before the pandemic then boom here comes
the pandemic and you're the Chinese are
you know they got the zero covet policy
you might as well have a zero cold
policy you know no one can get a cold
we're going to shut down the city of 26
million people which is Shanghai because
there's a kind of tame version of the
flu going around
um you know I'm not in charge of China
so I can't change that but I do know
what they're doing and they're doing
exactly what I just said next to
Shanghai is a place called Ningbo which
is the biggest port in China most of the
containers showing up at the Port of Los
Angeles are coming out of Ningbo well
that's all affected and so so the global
supply chain is is breaking down it was
already breaking down now it's a lot
worse now Along Comes the war in Ukraine
and you're absolutely right about the
wheat Russia and Ukraine now I know
there are different you know different
sides of the war they're in a fight to
the death but taken economically if you
combine Russia and Ukraine you're
looking at 25 of all the wheat exports
in the world now obviously it's a huge
number but but the point is there are
countries where they get 100 of their
wheat from one of those two places
Lebanon gets a hundred percent of its
wheat from uh Ukraine Lebanon is the
best case anyway and now there's there's
no food there are countries in Africa
where people are going to be starving so
that is a um that's going to be not just
an economic dislocation and an
inflationary Vector it is that but
you're looking at humanitarian tragedies
on a colossal scale you're looking at
starvation
um in a lot of cases but let's not and
that's bad enough let's not stop with
wheat for example the U.S said um we're
not allowing any advanced stomach
conductors maybe no any any
semiconductors at all or high-tech
equipment to be exported to Russia
certainly can't come from the U.S but
the United States went further we said
we don't care who you are if you're
China Taiwan Japan anyone else if you're
manufacturing advanced technology uh
equipment and tools and using
semiconductors that involve U.S
technology or U.S tools because you're
operating under a license for the United
States you can't export to Russia either
now enforcement is another issue but so
far the Chinese have kind of towed that
line so um so we've cut off visually
Advanced Equipment semiconductors to
Russia okay that affects defense and uh
Aeronautics and a lot of other
Industries well Russia said okay two can
play uh how do you make semiconductors
well you know they're Wafers and uh
they're different layers you need the
chemicals and the Strategic metals to
make those layers but more to the point
you you etch the circuits uh on the
semiconductor with lasers
how do you power the lasers well there's
a certain kind of compressed Neon gas
that's used to power the lasers to etch
the semiconductors
70 percent of that processed gas comes
from a single plant in Odessa in Ukraine
so now it's like this isn't how no
semiconductors for Russia this is no
semiconductors for the world because the
world can't get the Neon gas they need
to run the lasers to etch the
semiconductors now can you replace it
yeah you can probably replace most
things but it takes years in some cases
um to do that and and say well would you
why hasn't this shown up already well
first of all it is I mean Tesla assembly
lines are shut down uh try getting a new
car in the United States you know good
luck
um you know cars are cars have fourteen
hundred semiconductors they're basically
computers on Wheels you know when I was
a kid you'd learn how to stick a
screwdriver in a carburetor if the
engine was flooded they don't even have
carburetors anymore they got something
good semiconductors so these Supply
chains are breaking down and like why
isn't it worse right now the answer is
they um manufacturers and intermediate
uh participants in the global supply
chain have what they call Safety stock
it's it's a little extra inventory maybe
more than you want but just in case
there's a minor disruption well this
isn't a minor disruption this is a major
disruption you can get you can get by
for 30 days using it for Safety stock
but then you got to go reorder that's
when you find out that either the price
is tripled or it's just not available at
any price or even if you can put the
order in the shipping lanes and the
transit lines are broken down and you're
not going to see it for next year until
next year so that's
um and and I can I could go on and on
probably don't need to go into every
example but I can assure uh the
listeners and viewers that it's a really
long list uh you know aluminum Platinum
Palladium
um you know everyone loves EBS electric
vehicles you know the Teslas or whatever
um okay Tesla on one of my batteries
leave aside the fact that you have to
charge the batteries with coal-fired
plants uh that's a that's a issue for
another day I mean 58 of China's energy
comes from coal not oil not natural gas
not uranium coal uh and they're leading
producer of electronic Vehicles so that
basically uh emitting huge amounts of
CO2 to charge up your Tesla it's not
like the electricity comes out of uh of
the air uh but but that aside uh you
can't build those cars without batteries
but what's in a battery nickel where's
nickel come from comes from Russia you
know lithium ion
um the you know the where's the lithium
come from comes from mines many of which
are in Russia
um how does Boeing make aircrafts well
you need a lot of aluminum where does it
come from Russia titanium Russia I mean
the um there's a group called the five
eyes you may have heard of them but five
eyes are
five kind of
Anglo-Saxon Community if you want to
think of it that way who share
intelligence they share intelligence
that they they would not share with
anyone else even allies and the five
eyes are UK Australia Canada New Zealand
and the United States
and they share intelligence among
themselves well they've now kind of
expanded their mandate if you will and
the five eyes recently came out with a
report I just caught the five eyes
report it's got a longer official title
uh and they looked at what we're talking
about they looked at Global Supply
chains from a from a strategic
dependence point of view and what they
did they identified over 5 000
categories of goods
um intermediate Goods Source Goods
finished goods Etc and they look at all
the countries in the world and they ask
themselves two questions number one uh
how much of your supply of that good do
you import
and then number two
is more than 50 of that Supply from a
single source
and if the answer to both questions was
you well the first question is is what
it is but if that's a high number and
more than half comes from a single
Source you would consider strategically
dependent on that Source it's just kind
of a little algorithm they ran it and
the results were shocking I read the
report
um
you know I mean I 100 of the Aspen in
New Zealand comes in China so uh if
you're in a trade war with China don't
uh you know don't look for relief in a
hangover because you're not going to get
any aspirin but on a serious note
um the dependencies are huge UK was
actually a little better a little less
dependent than some of the others but
Canada the US
um you know Boeing gets 35 percent of
the aluminum that they use in aircraft
manufacturing from Russia well you cut
that off good luck getting new planes
you know Etc
um Pharmaceuticals uh strategic Metals
uh oil and natural gas obviously wheat
uh out with the biggest one maybe
fertilizer uh like oh no wheat from
Ukraine that's a problem well how about
no wheat from the United States
because you can't get the fertilizer
this is we're you know it's spraying in
the northern hemisphere this is planting
season right now uh people who are
getting fertilizer are paying triple
what they paid last year and there are
shortages so uh you know good luck with
a bumper crop uh next September because
a lot of the planning is not going to
happen so this is uh we're living in a
world of very short attention spans kind
of insect level attention spans but the
world goes on with leads and lags and a
lot of things I'm talking about they
don't happen overnight they are
happening but the impact might show up
in three months or six months or a year
Etc but it's very easy to see the
inflationary potential of all this so
you've got two things going on at once
shortages and supply chain disruptions
so you might not be able to get Goods I
don't know I've been in the UK lately I
wish I had I've gone there but it's hard
to travel these days but um at least in
the United States you go to the
supermarkets uh and the shelves are
partly bare not it's not like every
shelf is bare like you know East Germany
in 1956 but there's like you know hey
there's no peanut butter this week
There's no chips here the soda is gone
Etc
um and and then you know for example I
like a particular brand of salsa a hot
salsa and I'll go and there's none there
there's none on the Shelf I'll go again
and there's none on the Shelf so the
third visit they got a case in okay I'll
buy half the case because I'm not I'm
not going to take it I'm not usually buy
two jars but I might buy Six jars or
eight jars because I don't know when I'm
gonna see it again of course I'm
hoarding right and I'm contributing to
the supply chain shortage because the
next person is not going to get any but
that's my response function to the fact
that I got shut out the last two times
Well everyone's doing the same thing
that's just human nature so it's just
getting worse but uh shortages yes some
of these will be critical in terms of
manufacturing uh and some of them will
be uh tragic in terms of starvation and
higher prices across the board
hey Francis do you like privacy of
course I do I don't want the feds
knowing my business in case I get
whacked because I got too close to the
truth the man is everywhere and Truth
Seekers like me need to be careful mate
you're a burnout former primary school
teacher who spends too much time on
miamifatin cell.com just because you
read that the world is run by a cabala
lizards doesn't mean it's actually true
I've never said the world is run by a
cabala lizards but they are definitely
tracking my online activity well if you
are worried about your data being mined
by big Tech and sold off to third
parties all around the globe then start
mail is the email provider for you the
email accounts you use aren't free
they're mining your accounts and email
for data as we speak this data can then
be sold on to a whole host of different
companies startmail keeps your messages
private every email can be encrypted
even if the recipient doesn't use
encryption when you delete an email in
start mail it's gone forever stormill
uses her own service not Amazon
this means they can't be put out of
business like parlor switching to start
mail is dead easy you can easily
transfer all your current email data so
you don't need to start from scratch
your cyber security has never been more
at risk email snoops and scammers are
taking advantage of the pandemic as
fishing has skyrocketed in the last year
take control of your privacy with start
mail before it's too late sign up today
and you'll get 50 off your first year go
to starmill.com
trigger that's start mail with a t s t a
r tmail.com forward slash trigger fifty
percent off your first year
startmail.com trigger don't let the
lizards get you
every time we talk to you it seems that
we criticize globalization and we say
globalization is done it's had its day
this is another nail in the coffin for
globalization isn't this the final nail
in the coffin for globalization
it's a great question Francis I would I
would put it slightly differently
um and this is the thesis of my uh my
new book as I was writing about it but
it won't be out for a while uh what's it
called Jim tell everybody what it's
called uh it's called sold out
so you know hey go to the store you're
sold out sorry but uh it's
um uh obviously it has a lot more scope
than that but the the uh yeah I started
I met I make the point that Supply
chains have been around since the Bronze
Age that's not new but what is new is
the science of Supply Chain management
that's new because we needed the
computing power to turn it into a
science and mathematical algorithms and
so forth so I talked to a guy
um who probably more than any individual
on the planet is responsible for the
global supply chain no one did a
single-handedly but this guy both for
his own company which is a model of
seamless Global integration as well as
the fact that it's a tech company that
provided the tools to all the other
companies in the world so this guy gets
kind of gets the credit and uh he said
to me he said Jim you have to understand
he said it took us 30 years to build
this roughly 1989 with the father Berlin
Wall to 2019 just before the pandemic
took us 30 years to build it we blew it
up in uh you know two or three years and
we can't build it overnight we can't
rebuild it overnight it's going to take
five ten years to rebuild this so you
know war in Ukraine or not
um this this is not going to be remedy
easily now the question is and this
Prince is this this is your question
what what replaces it is it the end of
globalization or is there a new phase of
globalization and I I think it's the
latter but but what I mean by that is
China and the us are going to decoupling
decouple and that must have again some
of these things are happening anyway the
war made it worse
the pandemic made it worse but it was
happening anyway Xi Jinping is has now
elevated himself through National Party
congresses and other ideological means
to the role of the new Mao Zedong uh so
you know the The zhangjamin hujin Tao
and uh these other guys uh like who
cares their footnotes dang Xiaoping you
know he gets a gold star but uh it's
really not mal and Xi Jinping he's the
new Mount that's the way to understand
it and he had decided to decouple the
Chinese economy from the US anywhere
before everything we're talking about uh
and of course Trump when he was
president was kind of thinking along the
same lines
um now they get abide and he's I mean
he's not all there but uh he certainly
got a globalist crowd around him but uh
too bad it's not working so we're gonna
we're gonna blow up the global Supply
chains we've we already have
um they'll be rebuilt but along new
lines so let me give you a very concrete
example people because I realize I'm
speaking in kind of big picture stuff
um
the the biggest semiconductor
manufacturer in the world and the most
sophisticated is Taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing TSM
so they uh then kind of Intel is like a
close second they're both really good
they're down to five nanometer uh you
know chips uh working on three but the
best the Chinese can do is maybe I don't
know 10 or 15. they're just not the same
league same with the Russians
um
they have separately announced they're
building new Fabs as a fabrication plan
for semiconductors in the United States
a Taiwan and their 10 billion dollars
each and they're going to take three to
five years to build because you can't
you know start a question four walls
these things are very sophisticated very
hard to do right so Taiwan semiconductor
is putting theirs I believe in Texas and
Intel announces they're putting theirs
in Oregon
okay why is the biggest semiconductor
company in the world based in Taiwan
building a plant in Texas
well welcome to the new globalization
which is the US's onshoring all this
technological capability we don't we
don't want to be dependent on China or
Taiwan or for that matter South Korea we
don't want to be dependent on those
supply lines we're going to build it
here if you're Taiwan semiconductor you
want to do the same thing because are
you waiting for the Chinese Invasion
well maybe you know we'll wake up and
here it comes
um now there's there's a new military
Doctrine called the broken nest and it's
based on a Chinese proverb and the
proverb is uh if there's a broken neck
if there's a broken Nest how can the
eggs not be broken
those are even funny nasty eggs are
going to fall and they're going to break
too and that's applied to Taiwan China
may or may not invade I think the odds
of that have gone up I'm not saying it's
going to happen you know imminently but
but the odds have certainly gone up as
easy to see
um
if they do and and the big military
questions will the U.S 7th Fleet
intervene and we'll be in a shooting war
with China and we're sinking their
aircraft carriers and they're trying to
sink ours
Etc I don't know the answer to that but
I do know that either we or the
Taiwanese will destroy all the
semiconductor capacity in Taiwan we're
not going to leave that for the Chinese
this is
um this is square sure this is what the
the Russians did to Napoleon hey welcome
to Moscow but good luck finding some
food if if the Chinese take Taiwan
they're not going to have a
semiconductor industry which makes them
has a deterrent value makes you would
make you think twice about doing it if
you're the Chinese we can leave that for
the game theorists but but that's why
the the semiconductor industry is coming
back to the United States now apply that
to
Pharmaceuticals uh mining
um you know strategic medals uh you know
and a lot else
um and you can see the implications of
it so
so now I
hypothesized but I think there's good
evidence for it that there will be a new
globalization but it'll be like a club
members only
and the members will be you know the
five eyes and close allies and you know
let's let's include the French you know
they can they can join the club but uh
but the point being we'll trade among
ourselves what we'll have in common is
democracy you know a lot less and some
rule of law
um and some common culture Etc but the
Chinese are going to have to start their
own club uh and um you know maybe in
East Asia hopefully the Japanese will be
in our club the Russians
um who managed to be seen but um and the
big wild card is India because India is
probably like as we're speaking
surpassing China and population India
will be that if it isn't already it'll
be the number one most populous country
on Earth and
to their credit they've had a
functioning democracy since 1947 now
lots of other problems with socialism
and inefficiency and some corruption and
all that but uh but they're they're a
long-standing democracy with the largest
population in the world immense uh
potential human capital so where where
do they come out so that's that's to be
determined but we'll probably end up
with with a new globalization that will
be quite different because it will
involve a lot more onshoring less
Reliance on trading partners until they
sent you you do have to rely on trading
partners that's always a fact of life
it'll be a kind of members only club and
the Chinese will go their own way but
that also means things are going to be
more expensive
Jim
I find a picture you're painting to the
world incredibly Bleak because what you
have is China and its allies the west
and their allies and everyone else I
mean well they're screwed aren't they
because supply lines are going to become
more more difficult to come by they're
going to become more and more unreliable
there's going to be food shortages food
shortages leads to riots and therefore
leads to political instability which
then means that
certain countries are gonna well they're
gonna be plunged into chaos which then
means migrant crisis is this this is
huge
I agree with that uh and the the case
that you're not making me feel better
Jim well
um that's not what we get Jim on the
show for that is it well hopefully we
offer realism and good forecasting but
uh but I'm not I'm a matureful person
personally but I don't I don't let that
get in the way of good analysis um yeah
to me the saddest case and I've spent a
lot of time there Going Back 40 years is
Africa because Africa does have enormous
potential uh I always tell people Africa
doesn't exist you have to travel around
Africa to know it doesn't exist it's
like 58 countries from you know with our
section that's unpopulated in the Sahara
Desert I've been out in the Sahara
Desert
um you know Northern Africa of course is
uh is Muslim and Arab Arab speak Arabic
and Berber uh culture and descent a lot
of European influence it's almost like a
an extension of Europe in some ways
certainly an Antiquity that was true
then South Africa lots of political
problems but you moderate climate great
wine uh you know beautiful beautiful
part of the world
um you know a lot of people haven't been
there just picture it as jungle well
there's some jungle I've been in the
jungle but there's High Plateau just
gorgeous areas East Africa is mostly
High Plateau so it's got incredible
diversity
um incredible different cultural strands
and threads huge natural resources
what they don't have is a good rule of
law they don't have governance that's
just and I I don't know why you think
someone would wake up but but they don't
um
but they're gonna but to your point
Francis they're gonna have to pick sides
you know some of these countries and I
would say Zambia uh well you know yeah
Zambia but also Zimbabwe uh some of the
others are practically Chinese colonies
I know colony is a bad word and we don't
have them anymore but economically we do
uh and China has gone in when China does
a mining project
they create a lot of local jobs some
they they send in Chinese by the
thousands you know by the by the by the
plane load
um build company towns uh mostly
populated with Chinese strip the
minerals they're not uh environmentally
conscious I know I'm involved with the
uh you know gold mining industry here
and there and uh you know I visited
mines and uh refineries and
um uh Mills where they crush the ore and
turn into what's called Dory I mean they
have these vast you do use cyanide in um
in extracting gold in in getting gold
out of the ore but you have to have a
bad a case and you gotta account for
every drop and when the cyanide that
comes out has to be measured against the
cyanide that went in and they better be
the same like you can't be leaked
throwing the cyanide into uh rivers and
streams but they do in China uh they do
and the water is poisoned and you know
they poisoned something like 90 of their
fresh water rivers are literally poised
isn't
um so uh that's how they treat Africa
now
and I'm sure the leaders you know my day
that the leaders used to get 30 off the
top uh except for Mobutu who took 50 but
um but you know to the extent they're
still doing that if that doesn't change
then Africa is just kind of a basket
case but they could they could pick size
they could join this club that I've
described uh and and maybe benefit from
that but that's that's it's going to be
a little bit more like uh
oh the 50s and 60s you know they expect
you don't hear much anymore but the
third world you know is U.S and Western
Europe and you know Australia and a few
other places were the first world and
the Communists were the second world
everybody else was in the third world it
was synonymous with underdevelopment
corruption and and worse
um but we may get back to that where
it's you know the US and you know the
five eyes and the the club that I've
described on the one hand China and it's
um uh you know Tagalongs on the other
and then everyone else is going to be
third world or you're going to have to
pick sides uh Jim and uh it's in it you
make an interesting point because the
day that the the Russia invaded I said
this was going to be a month it was
going to have a huge impact on the world
and I think we're seeing that happen and
that you know I think it was it felt to
me like it was going to be the start of
Another Cold War and I think what you're
describing is essentially that in many
ways the the one thing that it's trying
to me it's kind of obvious out of what
you're saying when I was studying
economics University the thing that
everyone talked about was well no two
countries or whether McDonald's have
ever gone to war and this was like a
shorthand for countries that trade
generally speaking don't go to war with
each other we've seen that challenge
somewhat recently but broadly speaking
my concern with what you're talking
about would be that we're creating these
two blocks and when you've got these two
blocks what happens between blocks right
what do they do well they're competing
for resources they're competing for land
you know my father-in-law Soviet father
in law spent a lot of time and Angola
and other African countries because
that's what the plays were at the time
you try and control parts of the world
where you're not physically present but
you try and get them to have the right
ideology or to support you militarily or
with resources is that what's going to
happen now there's going to be these two
blocks fighting over land all over the
world physically kinetically but also
economically and culturally
something like that the first thing uh
Constantine you have to bear in mind the
guy who said that no two countries with
McDonald's would ever go to war with
each other was Tom Friedman who hasn't
been right about anything for 40 years
so I wouldn't put too much weight on
that um he wrote a good really good book
in the 80s but not not much since
um uh so yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't put
too much stock two blocks maybe maybe
three blocks uh maybe
four with some members you know kind of
switching sides a little bit more
Dynamic but yeah something like that
because well I guess Tim sorry to
interrupt my point was as much as we
have whole elements of what
globalization has done to our countries
and to what is done to our independence
and the ability to choose our own energy
policy or whatever was it something that
gave us peace which we're no longer
going to have that's what I'm asking you
um
it it contributed to peace yeah I think
you have to say that but and we don't
have it right now given what's going on
in Ukraine but
um I I have actually looked at some
studies on this it
I think the end of History thesis and
Francis fukayama he taught at my old
school
um the uh I think that was wrong I think
there was I went and I wanted to say
premature I think we did have a long
period uh from the fall of the Berlin
Wall till fairly recently where there
were not any major wars involving major
Powers
um at least not to the close proximity
that we have today but instead of saying
well that was The New Normal I hate that
expression but okay that was The New
Normal and now where things are falling
apart again that may have been the
anomaly uh and that things are actually
it's back to business as usual which is
war including war in Europe so I'm not
I'm not sure that
we left that behind uh as as much as
some Scholars some analysts believe
um but we may be heading in no we but
you know even in the in the uh 80s
certainly the 70s I mean there were
proxy wars all over the world Vietnam
Angola uh and elsewhere in the U.S and
Russia never fired a shot at each other
I hope that continues to be the case I
am deeply concerned about kind of the
warmonger element in the United States
um you know I studied um
uh nuclear war fighting in the late
beginning in the late 60s and the
scholars that I was reading in the late
60s as a college student had done a lot
of the work in the 50s and it was Henry
Kissinger he's still around my good
friend uh uh Henry Kissinger Herman Khan
Herman Khan wrote a book took a 700 page
book called on thermonuclear war
I don't think it's a bestseller today
but in the 50s you just you read if you
were in that field you read Herman Khan
uh a lot of it was you know kind of game
theoretic well
um well the nuclear weapons never went
away but we did get some treaties and we
got some inspections and we got some
changes and
um and people stop thinking about it and
I think it uh you know Millennials and
uh the Generation Z uh
I'm not sure they really know what
nuclear weapon is or how they work
um but we're but we're back it's back
now Putin uh has said not casually but
I'm sure it was calculated but uh you
know we may have to use tactical nuclear
weapons or at least we don't rule it out
that's what he said we don't rule it out
and that's just every statement of
What's called the no first use Doctrine
neither Russia nor the United States
have ever adopted the doctrine of no
first use in others we reserve the right
to use them first if we think that's
called for now going back to to her uh
use Herman Khan in particularly but
Kissinger and other Scholars will stare
they all said the same thing they had
differences different ways of analyzing
the problem but they all said the same
thing
don't go there
don't go there what I mean by that is
nobody wakes up and says Ah nice day I
think I'll start a nuclear war
let's see how that works out nobody does
that nobody but what you but the way you
get to a nuclear war is escalation so
you know you raise the na and I invade
and I I give the the some more troops
and you know I use missiles and so forth
and then you get to a point
it was somewhere down the road where one
size one side feels it's existential
they didn't start out that way but
through escalation they arrive at a
point where they're like you know what
now I've got to use I gotta Stop This I
Gotta use some tactical nuclear weapons
and here's where you get really deep
into the game theoretic side of it
because the side that's one size
thinking about using tactical nuclear
weapons and Putin already says we don't
rule it out the other side says huh if
you're going to do that I better shoot
first I better use my nuclear weapons
first because now you get into whole you
know first strike second strike counter
Force counter value I mean you can go on
and on with this Theory we don't need to
belabor it but but the point is you
actually get to a point where the side
that was uh least likely to do it
becomes the one that shoots first
because I think the other guy's gonna
shoot
um and and the dynamic takes over that's
really the point so what's what the
scholar says don't go down that road and
the closest we ever got until today is
the Cuban Missile Crisis and you know
you can fall
Kennedy and Khrushchev
um cruise ship was Ukrainian by the way
just for a historical footnote but
um you can follow Kennedy and Khrushchev
for for getting there but then you have
to give them some credit for finding a
way out and but that was a lesson to the
world
um I I remember those in you know I was
12 years old or whatever
um but the the you know the front page
of the New York Times showed a um they
didn't have pictures at black and white
map kind of thing I used that picture
but not color but um
it was it was North America with Cuba
and then concentric circles showing the
range of known missiles and everyone was
we say is is my locality in one of those
circles because that means I could get
bombed
um my wife asked me the other day she
said you think that this could turn into
oh yeah what she said is if it turns
into a nuclear war do you think they'll
strike us uh you know a very practical
question and uh but I can I can point
out the window here your viewers can't
see it but there are three nuclear
submarines nuclear attack submarines a
couple hundred yards away because I live
in Portsmouth New Hampshire which is one
of four
bases in the world authorized to do
maintenance work and refueling on the
U.S nuclear submarine Fleet so there are
three nuclear summaries across the
across the river well it's been nice
knowing you Jim
we're on the list uh yeah I do take it
seriously and I but yeah I don't think
it's a nervous statement to say we're
closer to that kind of outcome than we
have been since the Cuban Missile Crisis
I mean that is a deeply sobering way to
look at the world
hey Francis do you like podcasts and
politics no mate I'm a real man I'm only
interested in football birds and fast
cars last time you tried to drive a car
you had a panic attack when you got
overtaken by a granny she was driving
very aggressively and used disgusting
language for a woman of her age well for
those of you who do like podcasts and
politics then you have to check out the
Lost debate it's a podcast and YouTube
show for political eclectics who want to
escape their media Bubbles and engage in
good faith with ideas from across the
political Spectrum it's three friends
from across a political Spectrum
discussing the big issues of the day
ravi's a former Obama staffer and School
principal Corey's a former Fox Radio
News host and Ricky's a New York Post
columnist instead of being at each
other's throats they focus on bringing
New Perspectives to the table in
constructive debates that sound less
like Crossfire and more like discussions
between real people they sound like us
apart from the whole sound like real
real people bit that and they might
actually know what they're talking about
check the Lost debate out on YouTube or
wherever you get your podcast
I'm looking at the picture that you that
you've painted it's a very Bleak picture
but it's one that I agree with and we're
already seeing the effects from are
there any solutions or any things that
we can do in order to try and rail back
in order to maybe try and how can I put
it heal the wounds that have been done
rebuild Bridges Etc
there are uh and uh one of the the
scholars who articulated this best is
Edward ludvock
um I don't know if the name Rings Bell
but he was uh he was a classmate of mine
but he uh he's a little older but uh
his he's brilliant absolutely brilliant
and has written some excellent books and
and articles and his whole career he was
waiting to be the new Kissinger except
because you're still alive so it's been
a long way it's kind of like Prince
Charles but uh he uh but look look is a
big brain and he Advanced a concept in
the 1990s uh called geoeconomics now the
the geopolitics yeah Big Field been
around forever economics you know at
least since uh Adam Smith uh but
probably longer but he and they've
always been related you know those the
Napoleon's invasion of Russia and Spain
was because they didn't join the
Continental System to defeat the Royal
Navy blockade so so the two have always
been intermingled people forget that by
the way that uh
six months or really five months before
Pearl Harbor
FDR put economic sanctions on Japan he
froze their bank accounts and cut off
their oil supply
sound familiar
um so this so this is not brand new
stuff but what looked like did he he
said you know it's not even that they're
kind of related anymore they're they're
merged they're the same and actually
wars in the future will be fought
economically more so than kinetically
and I by the way I I teach a seminar on
exactly this topic um
at the U.S army war College down in
Carlisle Pennsylvania but the the
seminar is not limited to uh
people in the Army uh it's um because
everything's across uh everything's
joint these days in the US military so
my class would be an Army Navy Marines
Airmen
um intelligence officials and and others
but it's an elite group it's called the
advanced strategic arts program but
these are kind of mid-career you know
major lieutenant colonel colonel
um and then Senior intelligence
officials who are kind of in their you
know right around 40 late 30s 40 who who
have been singled out as the big brains
of the of the future of people who've
been running the show in 10 or 15 years
and I teach economic repair to the group
uh and I had my um a lecture coming up
and I said to the uh the colonel who's
organizing this I said well we've been
talking about the economic War for seven
years now we got a war uh a real one um
but this is economic Wars unlike
anything that's ever been done before
again the the Continental System uh
other uh you know FDR saying other
examples Lend Lease Etc uh in in two
ways number one like the war on the
ground is tragic we you know we we all
understand that it's it's little callous
to say well that's what wars are which
they are but it's tragic
um
but the economic War uh if you aside
from the human class maybe including the
human cost is bigger uh you know the
starvation in Sudan
uh might not make the TV as much as
atrocities in Ukraine but it's going to
happen and probably more lives will be
lost that way uh the economic impact is
orders of magnitude greater but here's
here's the point it won't be over soon I
don't think the shooting war is going to
be over soon either I think I think this
will likely go on I can see it going on
until May or June beyond that it's hard
to have a forecast because there's so
many uncertainties but um but the
economic war is going to go on for years
decades maybe it just morphs into this
new world new version of the supply
chain that we talked about earlier but
the United States said again none of
this suspect you know forecasting is is
difficult but none of what we're talking
about is really speculation you just
have to look at the record the United
States said
our sanctions on Russia will remain
until all the Russian troops are out of
Ukraine
that's what we said well Russian troops
aren't leaving Ukraine whether they
get Kia whether they take the West
whether they stay in the East whether
they just are take dumbass and
um they've already got Crimea you know
if the U.S considers Crimea part of
Ukraine while the Russians aren't
leaving Crimea for you know several
centuries probably
um
Odessa is the big wild card you know you
can see the the beginning of a Russian
era combined air amphibious assault on
Odessa
um the Russian uh amphibious assault
vessels they kind of look like aircraft
carriers but they're smaller but they're
designed to put you know 5 000 Marines
and helicopters and attack aircraft
ashore on very short notice that left
the Far East a few weeks ago and I
calculated the the sailing time
um to get to the Black Sea uh and came
out around mid April mid to late April
now there's a big question will turkey
let them through the Bosphorus I don't
know the answer to that that's going to
put turkey on the spot but my point is
this is going to go on but so Russia is
not leaving Ukraine
um even if there's a treaty or an
Armistice of some sort uh Russia is
going to keep its games Ukraine will go
on uh with what's left but if the U.S uh
is to be taken uh literally uh legally
sanctions are not ending
so you could have now I'm hypothesized
you could have an Armistice in June with
sanctions going on for three or four
years or longer so unless the US
modifies its position as part of some
kind of peace treaty so so I don't know
I mean this that my point is the impact
of the economic world will be larger
longer lasting quantitatively higher and
maybe even higher from a human from a
humanitarian perspective than the
shooting War Jim that makes a lot of
sense and one of the things obviously
without any uh attempt to minimize any
of the horrible things that we've been
talking about whether it's the war on
the ground or the economic uh situation
which I think you're right and no matter
how strongly I feel about what's
happening in Ukraine the truth is the
impact of the economic war will be even
greater in terms of people's lives lost
or damaged by all of this right so
without disregarding any of that is
there not also some positive trade-offs
of this reordering of the global
situation in the sense that
um you know you've talked for a long
time about the dangers of doing business
with countries like China and the way
that they do business with the west and
we on our show have talked a lot not so
much with you but with others about a
sort of cultural
self-loathing that seems to have emerged
in the west where we're so internally
focused that we uh maybe lack something
to push back against and so we're we're
focusing in would instead do you think
that as a result of this much like in
the Cold War where yes the there would
have been economic cost to this standoff
between these two superpowers but it
gave uh the West a focus and something
to win and it also meant that we were
more united and we had a better sense of
who we are and we also weren't doing
business with countries where they were
taking advantage of us like China
right
um and by the way I'll answer that
Constantine let me just uh
step back for one second because I don't
think I quite answered the last question
is there any way out of this I yeah I
didn't give it extended analysis of the
problems there is uh and it's kind of
sad because uh all Ukraine has to do is
say two things we won't join the we want
tornado and we'll remain neutral
that's it yeah a few uh tweaks around
that maybe a little expanded version of
that uh and we have models for that you
know during the Cold War Finland was
neutral uh Austria Austria it was
neutral um you know until kind of the
very late in the Cold War so there are
models for that it's a classic world of
a buffer State that's exactly what
Ukraine should be if you're going to be
stuck between superpowers of the West
and the superpower Russia neutral is a
good a good thing to be
um all solensky had to do was say that
uh and get you know sign and buy-in from
the United States and Putin said okay
that's all I want you could have avoided
this war I've never seen a war that was
easier to avoid now the same thing is
true I've never seen a war that was
easier to end which is stand up and say
hey we're not going to join NATO we're
not going to uh we're going to be
neutral maybe we won't join the EU but
um that's that and make that enforceable
in some way so and I think that's how
it's going to turn out which means that
this is a an enormous tragedy in sense
that
the war the war is the the war is going
to end up exactly where it started
except you could have skipped the war
in other words if they had if Ukraine
had been wanting to make the commitments
that it's going to have to make at the
end of the day
uh it's going to end up in the same
place except for the human tragedy the
infrastructure destruction death you
know
Etc across the board so there's never
been a a less necessary War
because you're going to end up where you
started except a lot of people got
killed which is sad but what it means is
that there is a way out but it's it's
the way I just described
um short of that it's just going to be
like World War One am I read
you know thousand page books on World
War one I can rarely finish one because
I get like five or six hundred pages
into it I'm like this makes no sense
it's just death just depth uh but what
was the reason uh what came out of it
what good it was accomplished and I
can't answer any of those questions
um so uh but but getting back to um
uh to your your point of Constantine uh
it it's yeah we're gonna we're gonna be
we're gonna remake the world we are
remaking the world uh and uh it's it's
uh it'll be less sufficient
but more robust
um and that's that's always a trade-off
and resilient is another word
um that's always a trade-off if you want
robustness and resilience there's a
price associated with it if you um
you know we all have Insurance
homeowners insurance you know against
fire and flood and all that stuff but
and we hope we never have a claim
and when we write the check or make the
payment for the insurance premium we
don't think we're throwing our money
away we don't say gee I really wish we'd
have a fire because I could put a claim
in we hope we never have a tragedy we
hope we never have a claim and we don't
think spending the money is a waste same
thing with the with the new global
system it'll be more costly less
efficient in an abstract sense but more
robust more resilient and better serve
our purposes China
um I'm shocked uh I mean I know what's
going on in China I've been there many
times and and not just in you know
Beijing or Shanghai I've been out in the
country I've been all over the place
um
genocide uh concentration camps a
thought re-education camps organ
harvesting from live dissidents without
anesthetic uh 30 million girls drowned
at Birth because they were girls
um atheist communists that's China is
that your business partner uh you know
Walt Disney uh Nike uh uh and a long
list of others that maybe two most
prominent names but there's a long list
and I think the answer is no that can't
be your business partner
um I remember during the Cold War when
pepsicola was the first kind of major
Western business to open something in
in Russia or Soviet Union they had a
bottling plant and you could get a Pepsi
in Moscow that was a big deal that was
like headline news all over the world I
was like oh gee a bottle of soda that's
it that was about it other than uh we
bought you know you bought natural
resources and uh we didn't sell them
much and there weren't many U.S
businesses there well I think we'll end
up with something like that in China and
then that'll put China on the spot can
China develop internal demand and
internal consumption ethic uh a
financial system a rule of law Etc to
displace
Western capital and I think the answer
is no they'll fail so I would look for I
would look for catastrophes coming out
of China but you know that maybe that's
the topic for next year or two years
from now Tim we've been talking at the
macro level and it's obviously been
fascinating but I think it's very
important that we talk about the micro
level the individual particularly now
there is some there's lots of people
from all different parts of society who
are listening to this and thinking oh
what what can I do what can I do as an
individual to better protect myself from
these financial and economic shock waves
what are they Jim
a couple things number one I would
um I would increase my allocation to
cash
um for a company uh yeah I did not
expect you to say that Jim well I had my
money on gold quite literally well well
let me okay I'll stick with cash but let
me kind of put that in a context
um the most powerful investment tool we
have is diversification now that sounds
like an obvious statement oh yeah
everybody knows that they teach you the
first week of risk management
diversification it's the way to go well
it is the way to go the problem is
people don't understand what
diversification means so I run into
people all the time they say well I'm
completely Diversified I own 50
different stocks in 10 different sectors
you know semiconductors consumer
non-durables you know uh minerals Etc
um and I say you're not Diversified you
may own 50 stocks in 10 sectors but you
have one asset class
stocks which are subject to conditional
correlation they in com markets yeah
they they're idiosyncratic but in panics
they all go down together or in bubbles
they all go up together so they're so
you're not Diversified so what is
diversification diversification is
having slices of asset classes that are
that are minimally correlated there's no
probably not zero but as close to zero
as you can get so what would that be
you'd have a slice of gold but I
recommend 10 people I have some strong
views on gold and I've written a lot
about it but people are surprised to
hear me say 10 like Jim why isn't the 50
or 100 if you believe all this well I do
believe it I wouldn't say it if I didn't
but you don't want to be 100 in anything
you don't want to be 50 in anything 10
is fine if I'm wrong he won't get hurt
and if I'm right you're going to make so
much money that it'll actually kind of
be the insurance on the rest of your
portfolio but that leaves 90 so I would
have a large slog in cash maybe 30 and
people say well wait a second
Banks pay me 25 basis points you know
stock market's going up why would I want
to be in cash that's horrible A couple
things number one stock market might not
always go up uh but number two uh cash
is the opposite of Leverage so leverage
increases the volatility of the rest of
the portfolio you'll get much bigger
returns but you'll have much bigger
losses if you have a slice of cash and
you've say you've got a volatile acid
over here which your stocks and other
bottle classes over here gold is fairly
volatile for reasons we can you know we
don't have to get into right now
um if you got that volatility and you
have cash it will reduce the overall
volatility so you can sleep better at
night cash is a great asset in deflation
we've spent a lot of this this uh
interview talking about inflation which
is here and you gotta you gotta deal
with that but uh don't rule out
deflation if we go into a recession
because the FED over tightens or you
know the thing about the the inflation
just the quick side it comes in two
flavors there's cost push and demand
pull demand pull is when individuals
um are are worried about inflation and
they start accelerating purchases like
hey better go buy that washing machine
right now because the price is going up
or better go by that house right now
because the price is going up that's
demand Pro cost push cost uh push comes
from the supply side not the demand side
and that's what we're seeing because of
what we talked about supply chain energy
cost the FED can't drill for oil
you know raising interest rates doesn't
get you more oil or natural gas so the
FED can't do anything about it except
kill the economy yeah and that'll cool
it off but when you pay uh you know I
put gas in my car I don't just read
about the stuff you know it used to be
45 now it's about 75 well when that's
multiply that by 200 million cars uh
Across America what happens is it
reduces your discretionary income if
you're paying another 30 bucks at the
pump twice a week then you're not going
to go out to dinner Friday night you're
not going to you know take a vacation
whatever it may be so that depresses all
those other areas so there is this
recursive function so don't rule out
deflation down the road not right away
but you know maybe next year so cash but
here's the here's the biggest value of
cash
it gives you optionality and people
don't understand this uh what if I said
to you hey I'll sell you I'll sell you a
call option and not the at the market
call option on every asset class in the
world you can gee that sounds kind of
valuable you know well that's what cash
is you when things are crashing you're
the one who can go shopping and nobody's
better at this than Warren Buffett he's
got his cash level at Berkshire Hathaway
is that an all-time high so there's a
place for that you can have some stocks
but I would look at the energy sector I
mean this um you know I've done a lot of
work in climate change I mean climate
change is real okay let's start there uh
I used to live on a for 10 years on a
beautiful body of water Long Island
Sound you can fish and swim and sail and
uh do all kinds of things create
lobsters uh but um it's the shape it is
because it used to be a glacier on the
last ice age it was the lowest latitude
of glaciation in the northern hemisphere
uh that's why it has a rocky Coast so
there's climate change it was a glacier
now it's uh now you can go sailing so
it's real but it's slow and they'll stop
at the existential crisis in 10 years
they've had a rolling 10-year uh
doomsday for 40 years so uh that lacks
credibility there is no
um climate crisis there is no
existential crisis there so you have to
Discount the climate alarm us
um and they want
um you know wind turbines and solar and
maybe a couple other so-called renewable
sources I actually built and I own the
law largest non-commercial solar module
field in New England and I run my house
off it it produces about 7.5 kilowatt
hours uh so I know a little bit about it
and what I know is it doesn't work at
night
it doesn't work it doesn't work in snow
it doesn't work it rains it doesn't work
in really cloudy days by the way you
don't run your house off a solar modules
you run your house off of batteries yeah
and the modules charge the battery so
you watch the battery level that's how
you manage it
um don't run the uh you know the
dishwasher on a cloudy day but uh so it
works fine but if you think you can run
cities with that forget it I mean I had
to clear three acres uh to put up my
Towers people said why'd you clear three
acres they don't take up that much room
I said well have you ever heard of trees
there's no trees in the desert but they
have them where I live and you don't
want to tree falling on your Tower so
it's just not practical uh at that scale
um and even if you thought it was and it
isn't that's that's very clear but here
comes uh you know wind turbines and
um solar and I'm not against it I could
say I own one but uh but they're not
scalable they're intermittent you can
and they don't give you the base power
uh Baseline power you need to run the
modern power grid I mean well here's
Global demand okay so the Gap the gap's
getting bigger it's not getting smaller
Renewables whatever the pros and cons
are not closing the Gap the gap's
getting bigger there is no substitute
for oil and natural gas and uranium you
gotta you got to put uranium in the mix
and hydro if you live in Quebec that's
great a lot of hydro but not so much in
the desert
um
and I've spoken to
you know without mentioning names I
would say you can go no higher in terms
of who knows let's just say board
members of the one
five biggest oil companies in the world
um
who who said yeah as he said we talk
about that but we we can't say it
publicly because we'll be you know uh
trying to you know change and drag to
the to through the streets but that's
just those are just the facts so
therefore if you have an oil sector
that's been bashed by the climate
alarmists and but you can't do without
it which is true buy some oil companies
you know when they're you know so
there's your stock portfolio private
Equity Venture real estate uh not
commercial but residential yes
um and you know Farmland it's one of the
hottest asset categories and uh and gold
so so that's diversification and that's
the kind of portfolio you want the kind
of season to taste and no crypto Jim
well look I enjoy
um playing roulette and I have my system
I'm still and I said like Marcel Basham
still working on it but uh uh the thing
the reason I prefer roulette to crypto
is because you get a free drink uh when
you're in the history but that's but
that's how I think about crypto I'm not
a crypto Basher uh that when I was a a
teenager there was a popular song called
uh shout shout knock yourself out and it
was a nice dance but um if you want some
crypto knock yourself out go get it I'm
not bashing I'm not again I don't know I
don't own any I don't plan to I don't
recommend it but I'm not like some I'm
not lying down in front of a truck
trying to stop the crypto it's here I've
actually studied it more than all but a
few people and I've arrived at
ways of understanding it that are
probably nobody in the world really gets
although I've started to write and talk
about it so I think I have a very good
handle on the technologically
mathematically and
um
you know in terms of communications
Theory but uh
but it's not well let me let me put this
way I'll say crypto is not money
but
what crypto is doing is
erasing the definition of money
so maybe the dollar is not money either
and that's really the point it's not
it's not the case that Bitcoin is going
to replace dollars of global Reserve
currency that's not going to happen but
Bitcoin might contribute to a concept of
moneyness not money but moneyness which
is it's kind of like money but maybe the
dollars get in there also and we're
losing the threat we don't know my
thesis would be we don't know what money
is anymore
but we don't know that we don't know
it's like uh uh you know some metaphors
are better than others but you know the
saying we we don't know who discovered
water but we're sure it was not a fish
um because because the fish is in the
worm you got to take the fish out of the
water and it's like Hey where's the
water but when you're immersed in
something you actually don't know what
it is
um and we're immersed in electronic
um
orb if you will and uh it's erased a lot
of Concepts Concepts but we don't know
it and so I think we're seeing the end
of money
very interesting General I'm sure we'll
get an opportunity to talk to you about
that next time because I think it
deserves a little bit more than a couple
of minutes uh but as always thank you so
much for coming back on the show we're
going to do a couple of very special
questions from our audience for you from
our local supporters before we do that
we as always have our last question
which is what is the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that you
think we should be
probably uh debt
um and again it kind of goes back to you
know we're losing the concept of money
well are we losing the concept of death
and I've studied you know I've done read
and researched and done my own work on
the history of debt and of course we're
um we're seeing the rise of modern
monetary Theory and you know we go
around the US Congress I dare say you
you know 535 members you can't find more
than five or six who could tell you what
modern monetary theory is but that
doesn't matter because they've all
adopted it our fiscal policy in the
United States is modern monetary Theory
whether they whether the members know it
or not
um
and the theory is uh part of the theory
is that uh the debt can be as high as
you want that to GDP ratios don't matter
uh as long as the debts in the currency
that you print what's the big deal you
can always just print it and pay the
debt
um there are unmet needs in society and
to the extent that they require money
just print the money and and the leading
Advocate you know Stephanie Kelton as
professor at uh State University of New
York
um said
um we don't even need a bond market and
again this is from her book so I'm not
putting words in her mouth these are
words she said the the U.S treasury
market ex only exists as a favor to
investors we're giving you a place to
put your money if you want to but we
don't actually need it we could actually
just give wire instructions from you
know Lockheed and Boeing and and
Medicare to the FED they could just send
the money right to Lockheed to pay for
stuff why don't we have to issue bonds
and take the money and you know get the
FED to buy the bonds and then use the
money need to pay military contractors
just send them the money what's the big
deal uh so that that is what's going on
um
but there was a reason we used to care
about that because it was sort of uh
there's there's something behind it that
is being taken for granted which is
credit worthiness yeah we don't have to
pay off the national debt we don't but
we have to roll it over that's the thing
and is is your continued access to the
market if you take that for granted
you're probably eroding your credit
standing
um and uh uh and there's a there's a
reason we used to lower the debt this
goes back to David David Hume uh among
others and it was it was in case you had
to issue debt to fight a war you know
you look in the history of U.S debt is
is it's not a straight line from zero to
uh 30 trillion it it goes like this it
goes up and down you know adjusted for
inflation that's even more uh more
extreme but the point being
you would pay down your debt in times of
Peace so that you could borrow money in
times of War it was that simple uh and
the only exception I was the Great
Depression and you can kind of think of
the Great Depression as an economic War
but that was abandoned
um around 2000 but really starting with
Obama and Trump uh and now we've lost
the concept so the US is ill-prepared
for a day when
credit may be an issue and we may
actually need to borrow the money
there we go Jim we're going to ask you a
couple of questions I said for our
locals but thank you so much for coming
back on I look forward to reading sold
out uh and uh where can people find you
online what's the best way for people to
follow your work
um well I have a newsletter strategic
intelligence
um and it's uh it's the best value out
there we we have some more high price
products but uh for uh for 49 a year you
get uh 5 000 words a month I put my
heart and soul into it so that's a good
uh thing and also preactive on Twitter
at James G Rickards
r-i-c-k-a-r-d-s one word at James G
Rickards
Jim it's been an absolute pleasure as
always thank you so much and if you've
enjoyed this episode they always go out
Wednesdays and Sunday 7 P.M UK times our
raw shows are always Thursday Friday and
Saturday and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go we're also
available as a podcast thanks for
watching if you want to hear Jim's
answers to our last two questions from
our audience make sure to join locals
take care we'll see you soon
I always say if you want to slaughter a
cattle you have to herd them into a
shoot and get them into the
slaughterhouse and digital money
um is the is the cattle shoe so we can
all be slaughtered in digital form
foreign